[Music]
hello internet people today I am
watching Nick I know he he seemed
unhappy he said he saw what said he said
I'm not his brother anymore
it hurts me but I still brother of me
and I want to help you so to make
funding I make a patreon campaign every
week patreon campaign I make special
video for you sexy video show you how
move body show you how make the energy
show you how to make the sexy uh-huh
because you need more than sexy I think
everybody needs more than sexy so I make
patreon campaign you join that I have
the money and I used to make the Nick
happy ok so i'll together we all be
having you be happy you sexy I have Nick
Nick be happy no way I'll be happy
together
ok so I see you with private sexy video
on patreon campaign ok
[Music]